じゃあドクター始めた皆は卵知っているだろうかええっ
または知らないないんでしょいないと思うんですけども卵って結構いろんなサイズ感が
あってもちろん料理に使われるたまま中にば鳥さんが部分のかなちっちゃめの卵なん
ですけども
食用の卵でめちゃくちゃでかい卵の代表例としてダチョウの卵というものがございます
いつだったか私も過去に動画で使ったことがあるんだからなんか卵ってなんとかしたら
スーパーボウル
になるらしくてそれだツアーの卵で行った結果がこちらスーパーボウルになるの
でしょうか
うわぁ凄いぶりでしたなので今回も実験とよりも料理です
こちらに勝ってるダチョウの卵を使って of rice 作りたいと思います
か youtube 見たですけど多分作っているとそんなになかったそんな時です
けど大ソナタを買わせていただきました
諸教ですね5000円沿いで実は脱オタもって代えますそういうわけでこんなかですね
ふぅ米系相当でかいですけどんだそのたまごこのだツアーの卵を使ってオムライスを
作ってみたいと思いますでつきっち
というわけで
+うだぞの卵を使ってオムライス作っていきたいと思います材料はこちら後半鶏もも肉
ただの油牛乳塩こしょう玉ねぎケチャップエラちゃんの卵以上になります
まあいうて普通動画内といつなんですけどもう僕料理法できないんですよ i だけど
歯科大学1年の時に付き合ってた元カノ東欧ライト一緒に作ろうっていう話で作ったん
ですけど
なんかこうやってお前とケチャップ力一緒にハートファインで名前とか書いてましたね
えっでは作っていきましょう行政は作っていきましょうとまずが何をすればいいん
でしょう
チキンライスまず好きな1つ来るなってことは玉ねぎっとたぶんここらへん使うから
ペット
えっとねー栗本が結構もう1機が住んだよなぁ
[音楽]
ブーブー言いますまず
しますバターラー油らしいねバター買ってきました
まあする時あぁまぁこれえっ
ない1個講座を受け入れます
いため炒めるねぇ
スポット橋のはなかったっさん
今んか骨もそうですねー玉ねぎが透き通ってきたらしようこそよろしいです
年別
[音楽]
白いい感じになってきたらご飯入れます大森2個入れたんでこれでたらいいんじゃない
かと思う
3種
何コレできるように食べるといいらしいですね結構いい感じなのでは汗ここから簡単
ですケチャップ入れます
[音楽]
弟子入りすぎて混ぜていくと色が変わるぽいつん
愛も憎的じゃない勝気なイス完成です山ってまずでパーフェクトを付けな実績でビビっ
てる自分でも最高
やって
病衣楽しい意外とやってみたら出来るってのが料理家まで
たいときで続いてはいよいよ卵を張っていきますプー
うううう
ん
うーんそれなんかた箱の中身結構苦手なんです何かあってですよも誰もいません
卵1個でこの日はヤバいでしょすごいなぁめっちゃを陰せよ程度これ混ぜます o する
卵17個分とかありますよこれ
いいした
よしで結構解けたんでこんなに牛乳とはちょっと入れてるっぽいですね揚々とがよく
わかんないかなことでたくさん入ってきます
もうちょっ中塩も色々見てるのか書いてあった気がすると優勝こそいただきます
はぁっよしもフライパンの準備しますね佐賀ナーベラーフライパンをちょっと引いて
揺れすぎたねこれちょっと国歌の歌詞で難しそうなんで頑張りますそれ卵を流し込みは
線にこれ売ってたフライパンで一番大きいでこれぞって回くらい変わらないですよし
ちゃ行くぞいくぞと行くぞいいぞ
ぜっ
台全部入らんけどねいきます
[音楽]
いやもうこれ以上無理でしょ1回これでしょ完熟っぽくなってきたら火を止めますはい
はい止めましょうと言いました
ででこれチキないぞ ok というのがこのでマジちょっと六付効果が多い国いい
じゃんねこんな感じだっけ品と違ってたらスイマセンまずはから乗ってこういう感じで
おk っぽいとああっどうでしょうピューッ
で多分なんだけど羽後境にしなきゃいけんとちょっとずつ
向こう関内なるほどなるほどへ本来ならこれで動くはずなんですか
なぜか私は動かない ok ok あれっ
あああれか
あーこれ多分絶対無理だろこれが普通だってこれをクレーンて積めるんですけど
無理です無理となると
ウソン
dai
大でも蹴りを景山ねべなが結果的によくねー
いやどう見ても同じでしょこれは細切れに米ですができます
[音楽]
ん
入った
あまっうまくに俺才能かあえて上げて無事完成しました
脱オンの田中の温度ライスデーねっ
世界を見てわかると思うんですけども超特大ないとか2個できてしまいましたヤー
たなもので多すぎた本当にびっくりするれたのがって何個がなんだろ多分普通に
では問題の味のほう確かめていきたいとおもいます
といういただきます
[音楽]
あれ
肉を食べましたその
泣くほど前なんかよく聞くんですけどダチョウの卵ってなんかや西区西都賀ちょっと
野生何がすごいっていくんですけども全然そんなことなかったです
量は追いつけばえーなんか普通に美味しかったって of life としてたら
めっちゃ多かったっていうこの大きさにコケて言ったらちょっとんまりでこんなデカイ
胸2個分作れるのは相当でかいと思うんですけど味的には特に何か問題なくと
いうか2においしいをもらいしだと黄色しますねえ俺が手水なるかもしれないな
ただのマジでを買った普通なんか1日のとっちゃダメだ業の卵を食ったような気がし
ますよ皆さんもぜひ圧をの卵があったら
ぐらいで作ってみたいいかがでしょうか食べるのは水書4人です
[音楽]
pou dou dou
持っています
だったんですかね矢野大丈夫大丈夫なんだってはじめさんが作ってるんですよねいや
だいじょうぶ兜の人が入ってるでしょ
入ってないですねから普通に勝てる時何も今月ですっ
プープーん
うん
どーすか味は
雨水でも
それに美味しいですよ
それですねー
ダチョウの卵のオムライスです
は超ん
[音楽]
goo